and adele congratulations  tuesday night three brits  do they do they give you the wink do you  know at all i knew i'd won one of them  i'm not gonna lie i knew i better the  other two no i didn't nice surprise i  know yeah i'm really really happy and i  don't know if anyone noticed on tuesday  night when you were sat on the piano  singing a microphone in right hand i  thought left hand didn't move as much as  normal it seemed heavier  than normal  is there i mean as if i would ever tell  anyone if i was or wasn't  i'm not fluffy though it's very like  yeah i have to say as a casual observer  it looks like you are  [Laughter]  all right okay  i'm taking that as a yes  [Music]  you